[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قبل ثنائيه ميسي و رونالدو
هل في فعاده واجر استطلاعا اخر صوتت فيه
عائله كره القدم الخاصه به لكن هذه المره
فاز بليه ما سمح للاعبين بتقاسم المجد
المقارنه لم تكن كرويه فقط بل تعدتها
الارجنتيني مقابل البرازيلي رجل الشعب
مقابل شخصيه المؤسسه المندفع امام نظيره
الهادئ المتمرد مقابل الملتزم العلاقه بين
بلاي ومرادونا كانت متقلبه كامواج سواحل
امريكا اللاتينيه تبادل الانتقادات في مره
كثيره لكن الاعجاب والتقدير سيطره مثل ما
سيطر على خصومهما فوق المستطيل الاخضر
طلع عندما سمع بوفاه مارادونا قال فقدت
صديقا عظيما والعالم فقد اسطوره وبعد
سنتين فقط فقده العالم هو ايضا هي جدليه
ومقارنات محببه لدى الجماهير لكن الامر
الثابت وغير القابل للنقاش انهما يقتسمان
عرش الساحره المستديره
بلال الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]